♪♪
I'VE ACTUALLY HAD
SOME CLOSE CALLS
WITH LITHIUM BATTERIES,
SUCH AS THIS ONE.
MY FRIEND ACTUALLY
HAD AN RC CAR,
AND HE WENT TO GO CHARGE
HIS BATTERY,
AND THEY SUSPECTED THAT
THE BATTERY CAUSED HIS GARAGE
TO LITERALLY BURN DOWN.
Narrator:
LITHIUM POLYMER BATTERIES
USE A DIFFERENT KIND
OF ELECTROLYTE,
AND THEIR RELATIVELY
LIGHT WEIGHT
MAKES THEM IDEAL FOR GADGETS
LIKE JESSE'S PAL'S
ILL-FATED RC CAR.
NOW THAT WE'RE MOVING ON
TO OUR BIGGER BATTERIES
THAT CAN RELEASE TOXIC FUMES,
WE HAVE TO WEAR RESPIRATORS.
SAFETY FIRST, RIGHT, GUYS?
RIGHT.
Jesse: THIS IS LITHIUM
POLYMER RC BATTERY
IN THREE, TWO, ONE...
Valerie: CONTACT.
-OOH!
OH, IT'S SMOKING!
AH!
-OH!
OH, GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
STOP!
Narrator:
IT'S THE PROOF THEY NEED
THAT A LITHIUM-BASED BATTERY
CAN IGNITE UNDER PRESSURE,
AND WHEN YOU'RE ON A ROLL...
HEY,
LET'S TRY THIS ONE.
OH, WHAT IS THAT?
SAME AS BEFORE, LITHIUM
POLYMER, JUST BIGGER.
MM.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT LOOKS SCARY.
IT'S AROUND TWICE THE VOLTAGE
OF THE BATTERY
THAT JUST WENT UP IN SMOKE.
VALERIE,
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
-YES!
-ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS BIGGER
LITHIUM POLYMER
IN THREE, TWO, ONE...
HERE WE GO!
CONTACT!
IT LOOKS LIKE THE MUNCHER
HAS ONLY SUCCEEDED
IN MAKING ANOTHER LITHIUM
FLAPJACK, UNTIL...
OOH!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
WOW!
THAT IS A LOT OF SMOKE.
OH, MY GOD.
AND YOU KNOW THE OLD SAYING --
"WHERE THERE'S SMOKE,
THERE'S GENERALLY"...
-OH, IT'S ON FIRE!
-IT'S ON FIRE!
WE HAVE A FIRE!
-IT'S ON FIRE NOW!
Narrator:
THE FLIR CAMERA CONFIRMS
THAT THEY'VE GOT
WHAT THEY WANTED --
HIGH-PRESSURE COMBUSTION.
WE GOT SPARKS,
SMOKE AND EVEN FIRE.
AWESOME FOR US, BUT NOT SO GREAT
FOR OUR GARBAGE MAN.
WE ALSO FOUND OUT
THAT THE HIGHER THE VOLTAGE
THE BATTERY WAS AT,
WE GOT MORE EXPLOSIVE RESULTS.
Narrator: THE HIGHER VOLTAGE
CREATES A HIGHER CURRENT
WHEN SHORTED,
WHICH GENERATES
A HIGHER TEMPERATURE.